Oft ist es so,
das Leben in der Stadt.
Laut, hektisch, eng.
Auch spannend
und voller Möglichkeiten.
Als diese aber nicht mehr
genutzt werden konnten,
fühlten sich viele
wie in einem goldenen Käfig.
Die Pandemie hat die Sicht vieler
Stadtmenschen auf ihr Leben geändert.
Im Homeoffice kam der Wunsch auf,
durchzuatmen,
Freiheit zurückzugewinnen
und bis an den Horizont zu sehen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Idyllische Gitarrenklänge *
Corona hat ihn beflügelt: den Traum
vom Zufluchtsort in den Bergen.
Auf einigen Portalen
haben die Suchanfragen
nach Immobilien in den Bergen
um fast 100 % zugenommen.
Oft gilt: je abgeschiedener
desto besser.
Agathe Fuchs arbeitet
in einer Immobilienagentur im Wallis.
Seit Beginn der Pandemie
beobachtet sie
einen wahren Run auf Ferienhäuser
in den Bergen.
Wir haben auf unserer Seite
nicht so viele Chalets,
aber sobald wir eines haben,
geht die Post ab.
So geschehen bei diesem Chalet,
das 60 m2 hat.
Ich habe das Chalet besichtigt
und festgestellt,
dass es weder Strom
noch fliessendes Wasser hat.
Für mich war deshalb klar, dass das
kein schneller Verkauf sein wird.
Die Maklerin stellte das Chalet vor
einem Wochenende auf die Webseite.
Resultat: Noch während des Weekends
musste sie
mehr als 90 Anfragen beantworten,
darunter überraschende.
Dass die Kunden ein Chalet
nicht mal besichtigen wollen,
sondern direkt eine Reservation
machten, habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Ohne Besichtigung.
Die begehrte Immobilie liegt
in der Nähe von Haute Nendaz,
einer Skiregion im Wallis.
Und: inmitten idyllischer Natur.
* Fröhliche, lockere Musik *
Für 295'000 Fr. hat Agathe Fuchs
das Chalet angeboten.
Fast 300'000 Fr. also
für eine Immobilie,
welche im Winter
nicht einfach zu erreichen ist.
Das Haus wird mit Holz geheizt, Strom
gibt es einzig aus den Solarzellen.
Wer hat das denn gekauft?
Es ist eine Familie mit Kindern
aus dem Kanton Genf.
Die Familie wollte Ruhe und Natur
und viel im Freien sein.
Sie haben sich sofort in das Chalet
verliebt und waren bereit,
es zu kaufen,
ohne es gesehen zu haben.
Das war schon verrückt.
Genau solche Häuser
sind sehr gefragt.
Das Ziel ist, ohne Komfort zu leben.
Diese Käufer hier
wollen ihren Alltag verlassen.
Sie wollen ein Feuer machen mit
den Kindern, mit ihnen Holz sammeln.
Wenn alle mit anpacken müssen,
setzt das natürlich schon
eine neue Dynamik frei.
So ein Gemeinschaftserlebnis findet
man im Stadtalltag wohl nicht.
Flughafen Zürich.
Hier brachte die Pandemie -
im Gegensatz zu den Bergregionen -
Leere und Verluste.
Das Circle-Gebäude wurde
mitten in der Pandemie eröffnet.
Viele Büros blieben aufgrund des
Homeoffice-Obligatoriums ungenutzt.
Mit dem Ende der Pandemiemassnahmen
kehrt nun langsam Leben ein.
Etwa in den Räumen der Raiffeisen.
Chefökonom Martin Naef kann auswei-
sen, dass allein bei der Raiffeisen
das Hypothekarvolumen
seit Beginn der Pandemie
um bis zu 35 % höher lag als zuvor.
Wir hatten
eine boomhafte Entwicklung.
Erstaunlicherweise
hat der Eigenheimmarkt
noch ein Stück zugelegt.
Wir hatten Preissteigerungen
bis in den zweistelligen Bereich,
z.B. beim Einfamilienhaus.
Stockwerkeigentumswohnungen
sind um 7 % teurer geworden.
Und der Zweitwohnungsmarkt in Tou-
rismusgemeinden hat alles getoppt.
Da hatten wir ein Plus von bis
zu 15 % seit Ausbruch der Pandemie.
Als die Flugzeuge
auf dem Boden blieben,
haben die Menschen
die Schweiz neu entdeckt.
So wurde Freiraum
in den Schweizer Bergen zum Luxus.
Ich denke, es sind nur
wenige Privilegierte in der Schweiz,
die sich tatsächlich
eine Zweitwohnung leisten können.
Erstens muss man
hartes Eigenkapital mitbringen.
Deutlich mehr. Man kann nichts
aus der Pensionskasse nehmen.
Man kriegt generell
auch weniger Hypothek.
Man muss sie schneller amortisieren,
also zurückzahlen.
Und unter Umständen
ist der Zinssatz höher.
D.h. unterm Strich, wenn man den
normalen Eigenheimmarkt betrachtet,
bei dem der mittlere Haushalt
nicht mehr eigentumsfähig ist,
ist der Zweitwohnungsmarkt
faktisch ein Luxusmarkt
für wenige Privilegierte.
Wenn Sie einen Blick
in die Zukunft wagen:
Viele Massnahmen in Bezug auf
die Pandemie wurden jetzt gestrichen.
Sehen Sie aufgrund Ihrer Zahlen,
dass das zurückgehen wird?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Und zwar aus diesem Grund:
Im März 2012
wurde die berühmte Zweitwohnungs-
Initiative gutgeheissen.
Das hat zur Konsequenz,
dass die Gemeinden,
die tendenziell gesucht sind,
heute schon ziemlich
hohe Zweitwohnungsquoten haben.
Und zwar nicht 20-30 %, sondern
60-80 % im Wallis oder Bündnerland.
D.h., dass das Angebot dort
gar nicht mehr vermehrbar ist.
Ich kenne Leute, die wissen,
dass jemand eine Zweitwohnung hat.
Dem sitzen sie förmlich im Nacken
und sagen:
"Wenn du irgendwann
die Wohnung verkaufen willst,
weil du altersbedingt
nicht mehr Skifahren kannst oder so,
ruf mich an."
Das läuft oft unter der Hand ab.
* Ruhige Klaviermusik *
Tatsächlich: Der Immobilienmarkt
ist in vielen Bergregionen
fast ausgetrocknet.
2012 hat das Stimmvolk
die Zweitwohnungsinitiative,
auch bekannt als Lex Weber,
angenommen.
Die Lex Weber schreibt vor,
dass die Anzahl Zweitwohnungen
pro Gemeinde auf 20 % limitiert wird.
Der Initiant Franz Weber
wollte so gegen kalte Betten kämpfen
und die Betonierung der Alpen
verhindern.
Es sieht nicht so aus, aber
die 20 % erlaubter Ferienwohnungen
sind auch hier quasi ausgeschöpft.
Wir sind in den Freiburger Voralpen,
dem Greyerzerland.
Wie im Wallis gibt es auch hier
wenige bis keine Zweitwohnsitze
auf dem Markt.
Die Skidestination Moléson
liegt auf 1'100 m ü.M.
Für die Deutsch-Freiburgerin
Tina Schwab und ihre Tochter
ist heute ein ganz besonderer Tag.
Salut.
- Bonjour.
Bonjour, Tina. Ça va?
- Oui et toi?
Bonjour Sophie. Oui très bien.
Entrez!
(Frau) Salut Sophie.
Ça va? Prenez place.
Voilà.
- Merci.
Willkommen bei euch.
Schön, dass ihr hier seid.
Hattet ihr eine gute Fahrt?
Ja, tipptopp.
- Schön.
Nun, wir freuen uns,
dass wir euch heute die Schlüssel
für euer Chalet übergeben dürfen.
- Danke.
Wir freuen uns, dass es nun
einer jungen Familie gehört.
Und wir wünschen euch hier
genauso viele schöne Momente,
wie wir sie
in den letzten zehn Jahren hatten.
Gell, wir freuen uns?
- (Tochter) Ja.
Wieso verkaufen Sie Ihr Chalet?
Ja, gute Frage.
Ich habe mich vor Kurzem
pensionieren lassen.
Und wir haben Lust, unseren Horizont
etwas zu erweitern,
ein bisschen zu reisen.
Graubünden, Tessin und das Wallis.
Es gibt in der Schweiz
so viele schöne Wanderorte.
Und vielleicht machen wir auch
einige Reisen ins Ausland.
Dieses Paar ist keine Ausnahme.
Ein zweiter Wohnsitz wird durch-
schnittlich zehn Jahre lang gehalten.
Verkauft wird oft aufgrund des Alters
oder einer Scheidung.
Und gekauft? Bei Tina Schwab spielte
die Pandemie eine grosse Rolle.
Ich wollte schon lange
inder Camargue ein Haus kaufen,
weil ich seit meiner Kindheit
dort Urlaub mache.
Dort ist das Wetter immer schön,
im Sommer auf jeden Fall.
Es liegt am Meer.
Es gibt Pferde. Ich reite gerne.
Dort gibt es diese weissen Pferde.
Aber dann kam die Pandemie.
Dann dachte ich, es sei vielleicht
keine so gute Idee,
in der Camargue ein Haus zu kaufen,
ohne dort in die Ferien zu können.
Dann habe ich mich
in der Schweiz umgesehen.
Ich habe in den Bergen
und am See geschaut,
und schlussendlich
fand ich das Chalet in den Bergen,
das ich einfach haben musste.
Tina Schwab war bereit,
viel zu bezahlen für das Haus.
Auch weil sie als Kind ebenfalls
die Ferien in Moléson verbrachte.
Es war ein sehr gepflegtes Chalet.
Auch die Möbel,
es passte alles.
Weil wir es möbliert kauften,
war es mir wichtig,
dass mir die Möbel gefallen. Ich
wollte sie nicht gleich auswechseln.
Die Einrichtung
war wirklich Chalet-typisch.
Darf man fragen,
wie viel das Chalet gekostet hat?
Es hat 430'000 Fr. gekostet.
Mit der Möblierung.
Und ist es das wert?
Ja, das war es mir wert.
Das war auch meine Limite.
Ich sagte, bis 430'000, könne ich
mir eine Zweitwohnung leisten.
Aber es musste natürlich
alles passen.
* Gedämpfte Stimmen *
* Leise, friedliche Gitarrenmusik *
* Vogelgezwitscher *
Auch Crézus
liegt in den Freiburger Voralpen.
Die Preisspirale schraubt sich
auch hier stets nach oben.
(Mann) La chambre à vingt-dix.
Dieser Parkett ist toll. Wirklich
ein grosser Unterschied zu vorher.
Ja, der ist sehr schön gearbeitet.
Oh.
Was denkst du, wollen wir
den Schrank hierhin stellen?
Ich glaube,
wir haben gar keine andere Wahl.
Das Bett kommt ja hier hin.
Ja, von da sieht man
den Sonnenaufgang.
Bien, on va jeter un oeil en bas.
- Oui, on va en bas.
Das neue Daheim dieses Paares
liegt auf auf 1'070 m ü.M.
Die beiden haben
keine halben Sachen gemacht
und sind gleich ganz
in die Berge gezogen.
Auf das Haus aufmerksam geworden
war die Mutter von Yan Crettaz.
Was denkst du?
Wir möchten die Küche hier.
Das sieht sicher super aus.
Und die Kücheninsel
hier in der Mitte,
das ist wirklich top, Yan.
Wirklich sehr schön.
Als wir zur Besichtigung kamen, sind
wir als Erstes raus auf den Balkon.
Es war ein strahlender Tag,
und wir haben uns sofort
in diesen Ort verliebt.
Hier haben wir ein kleines Paradies
im Grünen gefunden.
Das haben wir gesucht.
Wir wollten kein Haus in einem
Stadtquartier inmitten von Beton.
Dieses Haus mit dem Holz
strahlt Wärme aus, das ist schön.
Jean-Paul Oberson ist Heilpädagoge
und Yan Crettaz
arbeitet bei einem Autohaus.
Für ihren Traum vom Haus in den
Bergen haben sie jahrelang gespart.
Nun war es der richtige Moment,
um zu kaufen.
Es gibt immer weniger Immobilien.
Darum haben wir uns
schnell entschieden.
Sonst wäre nun jemand anders
der Besitzer.
Und zu diesem Preis gab es
nichts anderes in der Region.
Die ersten Suchanfragen startete ich
mit einem Budget von 700'000.
Aber ich habe schnell gemerkt,
dass das nicht einmal
für eine Wohnung reicht.
Angesichts unserer Lebenssituation
konnten wir es uns leisten,
das Budget etwas zu erhöhen.
Wie viel haben Sie bezahlt?
920'000.
* Friedliche Ländlermusik:
Cover von "Country Roads" *
Auch Davos ist schon seit
fast 200 Jahren ein Sehnsuchtsort
für Stadtmenschen.
Die Natur und die gute Luft
lockten sie hierher.
Früh investierten die Davoser
in den Wintertourismus.
Das Interesse war goss.
Und ebenso gross waren die Folgen
für den lokalen Immobilienmarkt.
(Originalton) Auch in Davos
wird seit einigen Jahren
sehr viel gebaut.
Privathäuser, v.a. auch Ferienhäuser
und Blockhäuser für Ferienzwecke.
Zwar ist Davos flächenmässig
das siebtgrösste Gemeindewesen
der Schweiz,
mit 25'000 ha grösser als
der Kanton Appenzell Ausserrhoden
Die Überbauungsmöglichkeiten
sind aber beschränkt.
weil die topografischen Verhältnisse
ziemlich ungünstig sind.
Die Preise für Bauland sind
in den letzten Jahren auch in Davos
stark gestiegen.
* Tiefe, bedrohliche Klänge *
Davos im Winter 2022
Eben hat der Bundesrat den Grossteil
der Pandemiemassnahmen abgeschafft.
Die Zeit der Einschränkungen liess
den Davoser Immobilienmarkt
noch heisser laufen als sonst.
Wer in der Region
ein geräumiges Zweitheim kaufen will,
muss aktuell
mindestens Millionär sein.
Christian Fross
ist hier seit 28 Jahren
als Makler
und Immobilientreuhänder tätig.
Noch nie hat er
so viele Geschäfte abgewickelt
wie in den Jahren
der Coronamassnahmen.
Die letzten zwei Jahre
waren speziell wegen der Pandemie.
Das hat alles Bisherige
in den Schatten gestellt.
Aktuell gibt es
fast keine Wohnungen mehr.
Es gibt immer weniger Wohnungen.
Die Nachfrage ist ungebrochen,
auch jetzt noch.
Das ist das, was sich ...
Im Herbst 2021
war die Nachfrage noch höher.
Und die Preise sind seither
auch noch stärker gestiegen.
Um wie viel Prozent
sind sie denn gestiegen?
Je nach Lage, je nach Objekt
um 20-40 %.
Damit sind die Preise
in der Region Davos Klosters
noch stärker gestiegen
als in anderen Tourismusregionen.
Auch für Neubauten.
In diesem hier kostet eine
Vierzimmerwohnung bis fast 3 Mio.
* Düstere, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Die Fahrt führt nach Klosters,
wo Christian Fross das Projekt zeigt.
Verkauft hat er schon fast alles.
Das ist eins unserer
zwei Neubauprojekte in Klosters,
bei denen wir letztes Jahr
den Bau gestartet haben.
Ab Plan
sind schon relativ viele verkauft.
Die Nachfrage ist auch gross.
Steht das exemplarisch
für die Nachfrage,
dass einem fast die Wohnungen
unter den Händen weggerissen werden?
Nicht gerade weggerissen, aber die
Nachfrage ist stärker als früher.
Wenn man eine gute, schöne,
passende Wohnung kaufen will,
muss man sich heute
ab Plan entscheiden.
Überraschen kann auch,
was in Verbier geschieht,
einer der begehrtesten Winter-
destinationen der Walliser Alpen.
Hier können die Preise
auch bei 20'000 Fr. pro m2 liegen.
Verbier ist einer der Arbeitsorte
von Florian Steiger.
Der Direktor einer Immobilienfirma
handelt mit Objekten
der höchsten Preisklasse.
Wo sind wir hier?
Das ist unser neustes Projekt,
ein Chalet hoch über Verbier.
Wir werden es
auf Ende Jahr fertigstellen,
wenn alles gut läuft.
Von aussen sieht das Chalet
gar nicht gross aus.
Nein.
Das ist die Eigenheit
dieser Art Gestaltung.
Ein guter Teil des Hauses
liegt im Souterrain.
Von aussen
sieht alles ganz normal aus.
* Sanfte Saxofonmusik *
Ein grosser unterirdischer Tunnel
bietet Zugang zur Garage
und zu zwei
miteinander verbundenen Chalets.
Diese ergeben zusammen
ein Ferienhaus.
* Gedämpfte, hallende Saxofonmusik *
Die reiche Klientel
verlangt viel Komfort und Luxus.
Hier kommen wir zum Wellnessbereich.
Hier wird ein Pool sein
mit Panoramafenstern.
Auch der Jacuzzi
hat Blick auf die Berge.
Hier wird es ein Fitness geben.
Und da hinten entstehen
ein Hammam und eine Sauna
sowie ein Massagezimmer.
Das ist ein Wellnessbereich,
der kein Wünsche offen lässt.
Hier kommen wir
in die Unterhaltungsetage.
Hier entsteht
ein recht grosses Homecinema.
Und dahinter gibt es noch etwas,
was typisch ist fürs Wallis:
ein Carnotzet, also ein Degustier-
raum, und da hinten ein Weinkeller.
Die Nachfrage Ð auch nach solchen
Objekten Ð ist geradezu explodiert.
Unter den Interessenten sind auch
immer mehr Menschen aus der Schweiz.
Was kostet dieses Chalet?
17,5 Mio.
Ist das ein Rekord?
Nein.
Es gibt hier und anderswo
noch grössere und teurere Chalets.
Sein persönlicher Rekord
ist ein Chalet-Verkauf für 50 Mio.
Und so sah es früher aus.
Verbier war Anfang 1900
noch nicht mal ein Dorf,
sondern nur eine Alp.
Das Land hatte kaum Wert.
Dann kamen
die ersten Seilbahnen und Chalets.
Und dann immer mehr davon.
Heute hat Verbier 30'000 Einwohner
im Winter und ist eine Stadt.
* Fröhliche Rufe *
* Dröhnende Partymusik *
Sind solche Immobilien
nur eine gute Anlagemöglichkeit?
An einem solchen Ort und in dieser
Preisklasse ist die Kapitalanlage
sicher mit ein Grund
für einen Immobilienerwerb.
Es geht ja um grosse Summen.
Aber bei unserer Kundschaft
sehen wir nicht,
dass sie sich deswegen
für einen Kauf entscheidet.
Es geht viel mehr um Lebensqualität
und Familienleben.
Oder anders gesagt: um die Frage,
wie mehrere Generationen
zusammenleben können.
Hier in den Bergen
funktioniert das sehr gut.
Und es geht darum, dass man hier
sehr sportlich sein kann
und dennoch gut arbeiten kann.
In der Stadt ist das schwieriger.
Und ja, die Schweiz und die Berge
gelten als sicherer Hafen.
Und dann sind wir wieder
bei den ökonomischen Aspekten
der Investition.
Einzelne Chalets
kann man auch einfach mieten.
Zu 150'000 Fr. die Woche.
Der Preis spiegelt natürlich
den Wert des Chalets.
Inbegriffen sind aber auch
eine ganze Reihe Services,
die beansprucht werden können.
Das ist ähnlich
wie auf einer Luxusjacht.
Es sind z.T. sogar
die gleichen Teams.
Die arbeiten im Sommer auf der Jacht
und im Winter
in den grossen Chalets.
Das sind fünf bis sechs Leute,
welche einen Hotelservice
mit Diskretion bieten.
Jeden Tag -
wie in einem Fünf-Sterne-Hotel.
* Friedliche Orchestermusik *
* Jodelgesang *
* Mehrstimmiger Jodelgesang *
Die Berge sind auch ein Mythos.
Eingegraben
in unser kollektives Bewusstsein.
Die Berge als heile Welt,
als Ort, an dem man
zu seinen Wurzeln findet.
Ihr Bergparadies gefunden
haben auch Antoine Micheloud
und seine Partnerin.
Ich dachte, ein Ferienhaus
auf 1'800 m wäre schön.
Und hier sind wir auf 1'780.
Man verlässt die Autobahn
und fährt auf die Kantonsstrasse,
dann auf die Dorfstrasse,
es wird immer schmaler.
Und zum Schluss ist es ein Pfad.
Man lässt auf diesem Weg
alles zurück
und kommt an in der Ruhe.
Er ist schön kühl.
Hast du das Eis?
Nein.
- Das holen wir nachher.
Tu veux du vin?
- Oui.
Tu as pris quoi comme vin?
C'est un vin jeune.
Je l'ai acheté un jour.
Dieses Chalet
gehört nun für ein paar Jahre mir.
Aber schauen Sie: Das Chalet
muss 200 oder 300 Jahren alt sein.
Generationen haben es bewohnt.
Und auch ich werde es nicht mit-
nehmen können auf die letzte Reise.
Ob ich es nun gekauft
oder gemietet habe,
für mich war wichtig, dass wir immer
kommen können, wenn wir wollen.
Santé.
- Oui.
Siehst du die kleinen Felsen dort?
Vor dem Pic d'Artsinol?
Der Sessellift von Evolène
endet dort.
Läuft der im Sommer?
- Ich glaube schon.
Lass uns mal schauen gehen.
Es ist die Abgeschiedenheit,
die ich hier suche.
Kann man sich hier selbst finden?
Grosse Frage.
Für mich ist diese Einsamkeit,
in der nichts mehr da ist,
das die Sinne ablenkt,
nichts sich bewegt,
nichts stört ...
Das ist etwas, das hilft,
bei sich zu sein.
Hier kann man wirklich
darüber nachdenken,
wer man ist, was man will.
Es gibt einem die Möglichkeit
die Dinge aus einer
anderen Perspektive zu betrachten
und ja, zu sich zu finden.
* Alphornklänge *
Die Einheimischen haben ein etwas
weniger romantisches Bild der Berge,
v.a. die älteren.
In diesem Chalet im Val d'Anniviers
lebt Roger Theytaz.
Der Musiker hat die Erinnerungen
an seine Vorfahren
sorgsam aufbewahrt und geordnet.
Das ist ein privates Museum,
einfach für die Familie.
Und für mich ist es
fast ein heiliger Ort.
Wir sind hier
im Stall meines Grossvaters.
Durch die Objekte möchte ich
die Vergangenheit erlebbar machen.
Was geht Ihnen durch den Kopf,
wenn Stadtmenschen hier Häuser kaufen
ohne Strom und Wasser,
um wie früher zu leben?
Ich habe nichts dagegen.
Schön für sie.
Aber das ist nicht
die Realität der Berge.
Sie wissen nicht, wie es früher war.
Für sie ist es eine Abwechslung.
Aber für uns
war das Leben sehr hart.
Niemand hier, der das erlebt hat,
würde dahin zurück wollen.
Es gab hier nichts.
Keine Kanalisation,
kein Wasser, kein Licht.
Es war sehr einfach, das Leben hier.
Ich will,
dass die Jungen das wissen.
Et ça c'est plus que important
pour moi.
Idealisiert haben
das Leben in den Bergen
schon immer
die Menschen aus der Stadt.
Die Alpen waren der Ursprung vom
Mythos der paradiesischen Schweiz.
Im 16. Jh. haben die
Gelehrten der Universitätsstädte -
Bern, Basel und Zürich Ð
sich gesagt:
"Diese Berge wollen wir entdecken."
Nicht ferne Länder,
nein, die nahen Berge.
Und sie haben begonnen,
diese zu besteigen.
Das war ein spezieller Moment.
Gehen als Vergnügen,
war den Menschen, welche
in den Bergen arbeiteten, unbekannt.
Nun wurde das Wandern
zum Freizeitvergnügen,
bei dem man
die Landschaft entdecken wollte.
Das begeisterte die Menschen,
v.a. in den Städten.
Im 19. Jh. kam ein richtiger Strom
an Stadtmenschen in die Berge,
weil eine andere Krankheit
die Menschen heimsuchte.
* Melancholische Musik *
Die Menschen wurden von einer
seltsamen Krankheit befallen,
der Tuberkulose.
Die Menschen stiegen hinauf
in die heilenden Höhen
und ging ins Sanatorium.
Der Mythos der Berge als Zufluchtsort
braucht Symbole.
Eines davon ist auch heute noch
das Chalet.
Es hat nichts
an Faszination verloren.
Auch für diesen Versicherungs-
mitarbeiter war das Chalet,
das nach Holz duftet,
ein lange gehegter Traum.
Wir sind hier zwei Wochen nach
dem Beginn des Lockdown eingezogen
und verbrachten dann
zwei Monate hier daheim.
Es war fantastisch.
Es war der perfekte Moment.
Und es ist immer noch
ein guter Ort zum Leben.
900'000 Fr. für 130 m2
waren der Preis dafür.
In Anbetracht der tiefen
Hypothekarzinsen ein gutes Geschäft.
Aber ausschlaggebend für den Kauf
war ein anderes Argument.
Ich wollte meiner dreijährigen
Tochter eine Lebensqualität bieten,
die ich in meiner Kindheit
auch hatte.
Das freie Spielen in der Natur.
Am Morgen, wenn wir die Fenster
öffnen, hört man die Kuhglocken.
So erwacht man schon
mit einem Lächeln im Gesicht.
* Zauberhafte Klänge *
Das Schieferdach und der Chaletstil
haben David Hertzeisen gefallen.
Eigenschaften, die eigentlich
zur Architektur des Kantons Wallis
gehören und nicht zum Kanton Waadt.
Aber Marketing ist alles.
Die Idee stammt
von Architektin Karine Ringgenberg.
Das hier ist natürlich
nicht typisch für die Waadt.
Aber wir wollten
keine Häuser aufstellen,
wie man unzählige
rund um den Genfersee findet.
So hatten wir die Idee
dieser Häuser,
die von Walliser Maiensässen
inspiriert sind.
Sie haben Schieferdächer
und wurden mit Lärchenholz gebaut.
So haben sie
einen direkten Bezug zur Natur.
Die 30 Pseudo-Maiensässe
wurden in Rekordzeit verkauft.
Wir haben hier auch
Leute auch aus Genf.
Sie haben den ersten Lockdown
in der Stadt verbracht.
Mit einem Balkon 1 m auf 1 m gross.
Hier angekommen sahen sie
den Balkon von 24 m2 und sagten,
bei ihnen habe
das Wohnzimmer 24 m2.
Das Leben ist kurz, man kann nicht
immer nur an die Arbeit denken.
Vielleicht haben sich die Leute
schneller entschieden
hierher zu kommen
mit der Pandemie im Hintergrund.
Pseudoauthentizität
zu teilweise horrenden Preisen.
Das ärgert den Soziologen.
Es ist die totale
Über-Chaletisierung im Gang.
Überall schiessen sie aus dem Boden.
Das Holz holt man
aus den Ländern im Osten,
um hier die Illusion
von einheimischem Holz
aus dem nahe gelegenen Wald
zu kreieren.
Es gibt aber auch Orte,
die sich tatsächlich
so etwas wie Authentizität
bewahrt haben.
So auch Evolène im Val d'Hérens.
* Fröhliche Ländlermusik *
Die Menschen hier
haben ihre Traditionen gepflegt und
wollten ihre bäuerlichen Wurzeln
bewahren.
Ihr Land
haben die wenigsten verkauft.
Riesige Immobilienprojekte
sucht man vergebens.
Und die Bergbahnen Evolène
sind nicht ganz mit den
Bergbahnen Verbier zu vergleichen.
Früher haben vielleicht
einige im Dorf
neidvoll auf den Tourismusboom
bei den anderen geschaut.
Heute aber sind Orte gefragt,
welche noch ursprünglich sind.
So auch bei Vincent Girod.
Hier auf 1'750 m ü.M.
im Weiler Villaz
hat der Genfer
zwei, nun ja, Ruinen gekauft.
Er will sie
in Ferienhäuser verwandeln.
Ich bin in den Bergen
in Frankreich aufgewachsen.
Es war ein wunderschöner Ort.
Aber der Tourismus
hat schliesslich alles vereinnahmt.
Die Seele ging verloren.
Mir gefällt es nicht mehr dort.
Nun besitzt Vincent Giraud
diese Objekte,
obwohl er es schon
vor zwei Jahren aufgegeben hatte,
nach einem Haus in den Bergen
zu suchen.
Wir haben hier letzten Sommer
für zwei Wochen
ein kleines Chalet gemietet.
Eines Tages kam hier auf dieser
engen Strasse ein Wagen hoch,
der plötzlich einen Platten hatte.
Ich habe geholfen,
den Pneu zu wechseln und erzählt,
dass wir hier gerne
ein Ferienhaus hätten.
Sie sagten, diese zwei Objekte
seien zu verkaufen.
Sie gaben mir
die Telefonnummer des Besitzers,
und 10 Min. später
haben wir uns hier getroffen.
Weitere 10 Min. später
war der Deal gemacht.
So schnell?
Ich habe keine Sekunde gezögert.
Diese Fassade ist so schön.
Das wollte ich haben.
Vincent Girod
nutzt eine Lücke in der Lex Weber.
Diese erlaubt die Konstruktion
einer Zweitwohnung
ausserhalb des Kontingents
unter der Bedingung, dass das Objekt
unter Heimatschutz steht
und in der Bauzone.
Bonjour, Vincent.
- Bonjour, Olivier.
Comment vas-tu?
- Ca va bien, merci.
Der Architekt Olivier Chesaux
ist für den Umbau verantwortlich.
Il est puis au liaison
inférieur du bâtiment.
Hier einige Bilder.
So sieht es vor den Arbeiten aus.
Und so sieht es danach aus.
Das Baudenkmal
soll wirklich erhalten bleiben.
Man sieht von aussen
kaum eine Veränderung.
Du kannst dort wohnen,
ohne dass es jemand merkt.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Das ist immer die Grundidee,
wenn man mit einem Objekt
unter Heimatschutz arbeitet.
Dass man nach dem Umbau nicht sieht,
dass es umgebaut wurde.
Haben Sie sich
eine finanzielle Limite gesetzt?
Ich habe mich da reingestürzt.
Und nein,
ich habe keine finanzielle Limite.
Das war einfach
ein Herzensentscheid.
Wir haben uns gesagt,
wir schauen, was rauskommt.
Und es scheint sehr gut zu kommen.
Wir rechnen pro Objekt immer
mit ungefähr 450'000 bis 550'000 Fr.
Je nach Zustand der Gebäude.
Klar, das Budget
ist eineinhalb- bis zweimal so hoch
wie für ein normales Gebäude.
Aber das Resultat
ist natürlich nicht vergleichbar.
Wir haben hier die Chance,
dem Handwerk unserer Vorfahren
einen neuen Wert zu geben.
Solche Zeitzeugen
würden sonst verschwinden.
Auch hier wird ein unterirdischer
Gang die beiden Gebäude verbinden,
zu einem Ferienhaus.
Wie fertige Ferienhäuser
unter Heimatschutz aussehen,
zeigen diese Objekte in La Forclaz.
Diese sechs Landwirtschaftsgebäude
waren Ruinen.
Olivier Cheseaux hat sie abbauen
und hier wieder aufbauen lassen.
Im Innern sind alle meine Objekte
sehr modern.
Es ist wichtig,
zwischen den Welten zu mäandrieren.
Auf der einen Seite die Gebäude,
die 200 oder 300 Jahre alt sind.
Und auf der anderen Seite,
als Luxus, soll da der Komfort sein.
D.h., es soll warm sein,
man soll sich sofort wohl fühlen
und man soll überall eine Aussicht
in die wunderbare Natur haben.
Die Materialien
müssen roh und natürlich sein
und die Architektur einfach.
Nun kann man diese ehemaligen
Scheunen von Olivier Cheseaux mieten.
Ermöglicht hat ihm
dieser Geschäftszweig die Lex Weber,
welcher er aus Überzeugung
zugestimmt hatte.
* Zirpen *
Im Bergtourismus
gab es wirklich kalte Betten
über kalte Betten über kalte Betten.
Ich dachte schon,
es brauche einen Stopp
und fragte mich,
ob das nicht auch anders geht
und auch, ob man nicht mehr mit dem
arbeiten kann, was schon existiert.
Hier gibt es weder Restaurants
noch eine Hoch- oder Nebensaison.
Das ist sehr zeitgeistig und gefragt.
Dennoch musste Olivier Chesaux
sein Erspartes
und das seiner Firma investieren.
Die Banken
glaubten nicht an das Projekt.
Ich habe mir
dieses Konzept ausgedacht,
nachdem die Zweitwohnungsinitiative
durchgekommen ist.
Ich dachte, dass ich gerne reise
und die Menschen und Orte
richtig gut kennenlerne.
Aber fast niemand
glaubte an meine Idee.
Denn ich wollte ja
Nichts-Tun verkaufen.
Ich war sicher etwas naiv.
Ich hatte die Welt der Finanzen
völlig unterschätzt,
sprich einen Kredit zu erhalten.
Na ja. Die Leute,
die ich getroffen habe,
haben nett gelächelt
über mein Konzept.
Sie haben mich
als totalen Träumer behandelt.
Es gebe da ja keine touristische
Infrastruktur, keine Bergbahnen.
Sie fragten:
"Was genau ist Ihr Angebot?"
Ich sagte:
"Ein Aufenthalt in der Natur
und die Idee,
einmal nichts zu machen."
Das Nichts ist doch einer der
grössten Reichtümer unseres Lebens.
Als die Pandemie ausbrach,
wurde das Nichts zu Freiheit
und zu einem gefragten Gut.
Das Business läuft.
* Sanfte, friedvolle Klänge *
Zum Nichtstun gezwungen
wurde dieser Stadt-Genfer.
Der Kaderangestellt
geriet zu Beginn der Pandemie
durch einen neuen Job
in ein Burn-out.
Da bin ich hierhergekommen.
Dieses Chalet hier
habe ich schon seit 20 Jahren.
Ich dachte, in den Bergen
wird es mir gut gehen.
Ich fühle mich hier beschützt.
Wieder weg von hier?
Bruno Chevrey merkte bald,
dass er überhaupt keine Lust hatte,
zurück in die Stadt zu gehen.
Ich habe angefangen rumzuschauen,
ob ich nicht auch hier irgendwie
mein Geld verdienen könnte.
So hat es angefangen.
Dann war unser Jacuzzi kaputt.
Ich habe mich nach
einem nordischen Bad umgeschaut.
Im Netz habe ich ein Bild gesehen,
das mir sehr gefiel.
Meine Erstausbildung, bevor ich
Sozialarbeiter wurde, war Schreiner.
So dachte ich, das könnte vielleicht
ein berufliches Projekt sein,
solche alpinen Bäder zu bauen.
Das ist Schweizer Holz.
Holz, Wasser, Feuer. Ganz einfach.
Der Genfer hat also beschlossen,
sein Leben zu ändern.
Er will nun mit seiner Ehefrau
in Isérables im Wallis leben.
Das Paar hat hier
drei alte Gebäude gekauft,
welche es nun umbauen will.
Hier sind wir inmitten der drei
Gebäude, die wir renovieren werden.
Das hier ist die alte Scheune,
die wir zuerst renovieren.
Hier wollen wir dann wohnen.
Hier ist ein kleiner Speicher,
der vermietet werden soll.
Das Dach müssen wir schnell machen.
Es zerfällt.
Und diese kleine wunderschöne
Scheune soll auch vermietet werden.
Wir wollen einfach ein Bett einbauen
und ein Wohnzimmer.
Es soll auch Petrollampen
und Kerzen haben, wie früher.
Macht Ihnen die viele Arbeit
keine Angst?
Bis jetzt freue ich mich darauf.
Verkauft hat die Gebäude
die Stiftung Pro Aserablos
zum bescheidenen Preis
von 90'000 Fr.
Stiftungspräsident
ist der ehemalige Gemeindepräsident.
Ziel ist,
das Erbe von Isérables zu erhalten.
Salut, Narcisse.
- Bonjour.
Comment ça va?
Bien, et toi?- Tipptopp.
Hast du schon angefangen?
Nein, noch nicht.
Ich überlege mir, wie wir
die Pläne und den Ausbau machen.
Wunderschön, nicht?
- Ja, sehr.
Alles von Hand gemacht.
Man sieht noch die Axthiebe.
Und noch in gutem Zustand.
Holz mit Geschichte.
- Ja, wenn das erzählen könnte.
Ja, vielleicht
bringen wir es zum Erzählen.
Er kam mit
einem überzeugenden Projekt zu uns.
Es geht um sanften Tourismus.
Nach Isérables
kann man mit der Seilbahn kommen.
Hier ist hat es Ruhe und gute Luft.
Wir sind nahe an der Autobahn,
aber doch weg von allem.
Die Dorfbewohner wollen oft Häuser
mit einem Garten
und einem Parkplatz.
Vielleicht eine Tuja-Hecke,
um ihre Ruhe zu haben.
Das finden sie hier nicht.
Das Dorf leert sich.
Wir haben viele Gebäude,
die man renovieren sollte,
ohne dass die Seele des Ortes
verloren geht.
Isérables hängt über der
grossen Ebene wie über einem Abgrund.
Bevor 1942
eine Seilbahn gebaut wurde,
lebten die Menschen im Dorf
fast autark.
Das ist wie mit einem Baum,
der an einem steilen Hang wächst.
Der Baum muss stärker sein
als andere und besser verwurzelt.
Wenn man hier lebt,
ist das Wort flach relativ.
Wenn wir sagen:
"Hier ist es flach",
werden Sie sagen:
"Das ist doch steil."
Die Leute hier sind harte Arbeiter,
Bergler.
Auch Bruno Chervey ist schon
ein halber Einheimischer.
Er steht pausenlos
in seiner Werkstatt.
Ich denke, ohne das Burn-out
wäre ich nicht hier.
Ich hätte weder die Idee
noch den Mut dazu gehabt.
Ich glaube,
es wird mir hier gut gehen.
Ob Covid, Tuberkulose oder Burn-out,
die Berge als Kraftorte waren
und sind gerade wieder sehr gefragt.
Mit Folgen diesmal
für die Immobilienpreise.
Und wer kann, ist bereit,
diese Preise zu bezahlen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Lisa Pfeiffer